all right miss mara
miss mar where are you from where'd you
grow up i grew up in
well actually i was born in san
francisco california however i moved to
south america for four years
uh at the age of nine for my father's
work oh wow
and uh how do you describe your
childhood
it was actually really fun i actually
liked having the opportunity to have
lived abroad
it's not something that everybody you
know says that they can do so i lived a
pretty privileged life in that sense
and since my parents were from different
parts of the world
brazil and the philippines
respectively i was able to kind of
incorporate those cultures
into my life early on
and
it kind of helped shape who i am today
and uh what kind of kid were you in high
school
high school was actually pretty boring
for me i
went to
catholic school
so
i get sort of asking is what kind of kid
were you
right so
because i went to catholic school
everything was very
you know rudimentary very academic very
follow the rules we had a dress code and
because of all of those things
i was more of a rebellious child
that's kind of where my art
kind of blossomed
was
kind of the outlet
in a sense to get rid of all of the
structure and the rigidness in my life
art was a way for me to just create
anything that i wanted and it was a way
for me to escape do you see what you're
doing as a dominatrix as an expression
of your your art 100
not only that but i've also created fem
del mar which is female domination art
through the media of photography
self-portraits
and short films and so i've found a way
to kind of bridge everything together
from
all aspects of my life so today you're a
full your full-time dominatrix yes
that's correct in los angeles yes i'm
based in los angeles but i travel
domestically and then i also
have traveled internationally and met
other dominatrixes in other countries
such as greece sweden i was supposed to
go to the middle east and the
philippines
um
pretty pandemic so yeah there's a
tell me about your clientele is there a
typical
type of
is it always a gentleman
no it's not actually so for the most
part i get cis white
caucasian males who seek me out probably
particularly because i'm asian or
i represent myself in a way that is very
you know open to everyone
um i also have a variety of female subs
and in between so trans people who come
to me as well um queer people
and i love it it's really
rewarding what is the
what is the attraction or the
inclination to be into this
for for your clients
i think most of them they're actually
people in power
so they also can afford something a
luxury like myself
so they are
you know business partners entrepreneurs
lawyers doctors and
the whole gamut of you know the white
collar society and also some of the
blue-collar society and
they come to me because
they're usually in positions of power
and they
at the end of the day don't want any
responsibility
they want to give all of that up and
submit to somebody else
in their preference usually a woman
and
it's
they have all types of interests all
types of fetishes all types of
experiences that they want to
you know
live out that is a part of them so again
it's a reaction as as you described when
you're in school it's a reaction to what
they're
forced to do it in their lives yeah i
feel like in most countries or most
environments that are super strict
they're the most kinky right because
they for the whole day they have to act
very proper very you know socially
acceptable
right and these standards
don't necessarily fit everybody human
human nature is human nature yeah and
everyone's different they we have
personalities we have different facets
to ourselves and so kink allows us to
explore each of these and i give them a
safe space to do that without any
judgment
do you
respect your clients i mean do you like
them i do most of the time um you know
there's occasionally somebody who thinks
because they have all the wealth because
they are in positions of power usually
they will speak to me in a manner and i
will have to remind them that they're
coming to me for a specific purpose and
that i am not going to be talked down to
i am not an employee of theirs i have
nothing to do with their personal life
they're coming to me as a professional
and this is how i am so i have to kind
of restate that for some people
and usually they apologize and
you know everything works out
respectfully so you're you're
categorized as a sex worker but is sex
really a part of what you do so for some
people it is for me personally i've
never had sex with any of my clientele
my subs and fetishes are
just that like there is a sexual
part of what it is because the
definition of a fetish literally is
being sexually aroused by a certain
object or an act
so of course like
for me as a foot model i've been a fit
model for the last
you know seven years and i actually want
an award for my feet
um so people are attracted to my feet
it's and shoes and legs anything
attached to it but they're also
attracted to the person that it's
attached to
um and so
i play that up a lot and that has
nothing to do with me
receiving penetration or oral in any way
it literally just has to do with my feet
and my legs
where do you think
your interest in this
lifestyle came from
so
was it just the repression of your
childhood
actually it or is it or is it something
that's in in mara that's
i think it's a little bit of both so
growing up i was always surrounded by
people who were into sex
which is crazy because i just mentioned
that you know i don't have sex with my
clients but at the same time um when i
was in preschool actually i was already
in school when i was two years old and i
remember this vividly because this girl
named angela we had nap time and she was
the one who actually showed me how to
play with myself because her
nine-year-old brother told her how and
that it would feel good well at two
years old you don't know what the hell
your genitals are you don't know
anything about sex
um but i got caught we both got caught
by our headmistress and she gave us a
spanking with a wooden metric ruler
and i never got in trouble because i was
a top student so i never
got put next to angela again um
and from then i actually never saw her
again so i hope she's doing okay
um but then like when i went into
uh middle school and stuff like that
there were older boys who were
interested in me and
there were rumors that oh
so and so wants to have sex with you and
i was like what does that even mean like
i don't know what that means i'm like
seven
you know and then when i got into high
school that was kind of a more
rebellious stage and then when i got
into college
uh
i was in new york
and
new york
is a strange place that brings a lot of
characters together but i was in a
halloween store
and my roommates and i were looking at a
wall full of costumes
and this one guy comes out from behind a
black curtain hands us all a card
and then disappears and i looked down
and i was like foot fetish party
and i turned my roommates and i was like
i don't know what this is and one of
them did know because she said that a
classmate of hers
would walk around in high heels on the
weekend and she would get paid for that
and i was like you can make money off of
this so that was the first spark
of like monet monetization and stuff
like that that was different
you know in a sense of the way people
would think using your body would be how
long have you been doing this
i've been a professional and lifestyle
dom for over eight years now
so it's been a journey
and
what is i mean how does it affect your
your love life
so
i have a strict rule that anybody who
is interested in me or who i'm
interested in has to know from the
beginning this is what i do and has to
be okay with it and they can't pretend
to be okay with it in the beginning like
oh yeah i'll get over it oh yeah i'll
try to change her oh yeah i'll try to
save her from this profession this is
something that i choose myself to do and
this is something that i won't stop
doing until i physically can't anymore
so and you're not getting naked or
having sex with your clients no that is
just my rule but
but they
are probably often
naked or something like that so there's
like there's a kind of um appeal to
submissives being able to strip
everything down and just be you know in
their birthday suit because
they have no power it's a vulnerability
and in your most naked
sense right you can't cover yourself if
you try to you know why is that because
you're ashamed of something and you can
actually get punished for that you know
if a mistress such as myself tells um
you know a submissive to wait for me and
they try to cover themselves or they try
to look at me or anywhere else in the
room and i haven't told them
what to do yet and they know there's a
protocol to follow they get in trouble
kind of like school
but yeah
there's there's an appeal of that
because
you know they're
it's sensual too you see flesh
right and then there's somebody else who
is clothed so you're like oh why am i
the only one who's naked why why do i
have to report to this person oh this
person is dressed in an authoritative
figure right now i'm dressed in like i'm
going to give somebody an interrogation
you know with a military hat with you
know gloves boots the whole shebang so
there's there's a whole
aspect to why people dress the way they
do
um why we tell the others to undress or
let's say it's pet play and they're
interested in being my puppy
they have the
accessories to go with that and they
have to dress like a puppy sometimes
so the
um
[Music]
the reason
that maybe some of your client let's say
a male client or female
has been unfaithful with their partner
is that something they would come to you
for some kind of discipline or
they can um is that i'm just trying to
fish for what
what's behind them sure
so most of the time um they are
actually no i it's 50 50.
half the time i feel like they are
partnered um with spouses but the
spouses
if they do know
they kind of do a don't ask don't tell
thing they will give the permission for
them to see a dominatrix like maybe once
a month
and they don't want to hear about it
they just know when it's going to happen
period
there's other times when
they don't know at all and i'm okay with
that because again i don't have sex with
my clients i'm here to do
a job in which i fulfill
their
you know utmost fantasies
i can transform them into being a part
of who they really are you know such as
male to female
and
or i can just
you know have a fun day role playing in
scenarios like teacher you know
boss
executive
of a big company you know tax advisor
nurse doctor all these other things
sometimes it's in the person's
profession sometimes it's not
um but it's
how i see it it's play
it's literally play time for adults
it seems like you're getting a glimpse
of the person's real nature yes
and they don't show
all their friends and family yeah
because sometimes they can't and they
get shamed you know they're scared they
might get shameful they they're scared
that their spice might leave them for it
you know and all that judgment it's very
easy to just say
well in order to
not have to go through that
i'm just going to see my dom in secret
how often do they come
typically yeah
pre-pandemic it was probably
anywhere from
every month to
every few months
some people sometimes twice a month
depending on their budget
you know i have clients who fly in to
los angeles if i'm not touring their
city to see me specifically or who will
actually fly me out to their city and
put me up in their hotel or if i've seen
them enough you know in in a guest
bedroom of their
apartment or you know house
so it really depends on the person yeah
but what is doing this taught you about
human nature
a lot
[Laughter]
um i've never taken any psychology class
but this is literally all about
psychology and i feel that
the mind is what makes
people tick like that's where fetishes
come from because you see something and
you think about it and how it arouses
you and you're just like whoa
like it's so and they're so specific too
it's very niche it's not like you know
it's not just feet sometimes it's
the toes how they spread it's the ball
of the foot maybe it's the calluses some
people are in love with that some people
are in love with foot dust i in the
beginning i didn't even know what foot
dust was
it's literally like
the stuff that comes off of your feet
while you're walking around barefoot in
your house you know
like you can shave off your calluses and
people are into that too because now
it's like a bare soft skin underneath
there ready to be worshipped you know
it's it's things like that where
you really understand what makes people
tick
and how to tease and deny that tease and
denial is a huge part of you know what i
do and it's based off of really allowing
the person to
you know see it first immerse themselves
in it but not be able to touch it yet
and then
pull it back push pull push pull and
then maybe you give it to them at the
end as a reward if they've earned it
it's i'm not saying you're a
professional therapist but it's almost
like a form of therapy for your clients
it kind of is i always recommend them to
go see a professional therapist if they
need one
but i have had proven experiences where
i've literally healed people through
their traumas
i give a specific example where this
guy who was into tickling
was shunned for it by his first
girlfriend she called him a freak and he
was heartbroken because
the person that you love like i
mentioned before is not going to accept
it because they think it's weird
and tickling is the most passive like
it's not even
you know
that sexualizing if you think about it
but there's a fun nature to it and it
literally does make him you know get
into the mood
and so for her to call
him a freak because of that it was
detrimental to him and i was able to
help him kind of accept that he is into
this and he has fun with it now you know
so what's the most extreme one of your
clients has has gotten
what they've what we've kind of done
yeah yeah
so i could put this into two categories
one of which is humiliation and the
other one is like pain masochism
i'll start with the pain first just
because that one's kind of something
that maybe people could imagine better
and i strung up a sub on a metal web so
it looked like a spider's web
and i knew he that he was into having
his
balls and his nipples tortured and so
what i did was take a bunch of um
there are these forceps medical forceps
that can click three times to make it
tighter it's usually made for surgery to
hold open skin
and so i took versions of that but i did
it on his balls to kind of spread it out
and then i took clothespins and lined as
much as i could in rows
i tied his you know
c to
his
nipples and was able to hang weights off
of them
and i changed the weights so that they
were gradually heavier and then i also
put the weights down on his jewels
and then i took my whip
and um you know i told him to give me a
number and i would whip off
the
clothespins
that i saw that were put on his
jewels so that was one and that took a
very long time and was super painful
not only was it painful to have the
clothespins you know whipped off but it
was also painful to have the forceps
removed because all the blood starts
flowing back in there and it's
i always tell them to take a deep breath
[Laughter]
um so that's the masochist
okay and then the second one would be
more humiliation base where
i had a really high-end client who would
always get like the penthouse view of a
hotel that he was staying up and
we would go
you know strip him down
do a little bit of impact play which is
you know using my whip to kind of warm
him up to things
and then we would take out a red
lipstick and write degrading words on
him
and he would have to memorize
where those words were and what those
words were and say i am you know a
little piggy i am
you know miss mara's
so-and-so whatever
and
after that if he got those wrong that
would add to a punishment because he got
the placement or the word wrong so it
was a fun game we would play
and then we would go over to a window
and he would have to
exhibit himself full on with the
lipstick and everything
and i would tell him to say the phrases
to me
over and over again
and i would pour mineral oil on the top
of his head so it would kind of drench
him all over
i would smear it all over
him it was very messy
but it was very visceral and very fun
and after that
um you know i put him in the corner and
i told him that he had to think of
himself in the lowest place ever
sometimes he had to be on his knees
and he was able to kind of relieve
himself after that so
how is doing this kind of work changed
you
personally
oh i've learned so many things i've
learned how to have a lot of patience
i've learned how to build my business my
own business um i've learned how to
improve my artwork i've learned how to
talk to all types of people and
communicate my needs be firm with it
i've learned that i don't have to raise
my voice you would think that as a
dominatrix because you're commanding
certain things that you shout and yell
and whatever i don't have to do that
because if a sub is trained or if a sub
is really there to serve you
they are there listening to your every
order and if you don't obey it you get
punished
or and if some people want to be you
know impacted for their punishment
sometimes i even do worse i do something
that they
don't want which is no attention at all
i put them in the corner and say they
are in time out for as long as i want
and that to them is torture because
they're there for the attention they're
there to see me
so i've learned how to play
like mind games i've learned how to use
implements using whips and stuff like
that takes precision
and i didn't learn that overnight it's
through experience do taking classes
through approaching people that i love
their play style and saying hey i would
love to learn more
you know about what you do because i
love your style you know
sometimes even having to pay you know
pay to
to learn these things
i've built my own website like there's
so much that i've done that i've learned
how to dress myself how did you first
get into this how did you learn
when you first started so my story
started at a dungeon house um here local
to los angeles and um because i had no
professional or lifestyle experience
i was supposed to start as a bottom
and that was fine with me because you
know i was like i don't know how these
toys feel i don't know how to use any of
them i don't know what goes on in a real
session i only know what i've seen on
television you know or
books for that matter because media
hadn't portrayed all of this stuff so
mainstream yet
and so
i was
um entered as a bottom six months later
i became a switch which means you do
both top and bottoming and i was a
natural at it like
i stayed there for maybe three years
until i became independent
and
have been independent since
what comments would you would you share
with
a woman who is just in a straight
relationship
nothing like what you're involved in
because i think what you're doing
somehow and you know bleeds you know
bleeds into conventional relationships
there's probably things that you've
learned
that are a woman in a relationship would
possibly be able to use right yeah i
feel like
as a woman we have so much power we
don't even realize it because in this
patriarchal society everything has been
catered towards men um you know founding
fathers you know and then just like
wages i've worked in the corporate world
before nine to five four billion dollar
corporations and
did not get paid as much as men
um and i knew that because we would have
conversations about it and
now
i feel like i know my value i know my
worth and i i really love who i am and
because i am this balanced stable person
i feel like you can
harness
that
um you know because you're so
in tune with your soul and just bring
that out and be able to communicate
communicate your needs
and your fears and be vulnerable with
your partner the same way you would be
vulnerable to adam adam also is
vulnerable to her subs because she's
allowing them to be in her presence and
then creating this space for them it's
not just this harshness that you see you
know on on tv or you know videos it's
there's a sensuality to it and a very
there's a finesse to how some of us play
and
the softness is just as strong if not
stronger than the harshness that we you
know emanate
and so in relationships i feel like
really harness that womanhood that you
have and
you know if if there's anything that
ever makes you uncomfortable honestly
men too because men don't have the
ability to be this vulnerable as well
with their partners because they always
feel like they have to be the strong one
you know
just be kind to each other be
honest honesty is key i don't know how
much i can stress that you know to
somebody
and
make sure that everybody's on the same
page before any action is done you know
that's kind of the best things that i
can say those are great uh so you
mentioned earlier that you you do your
art kind of
works into this lifestyle of yours tell
me how that
works for you yeah so art not only lets
me express my
you know deepest desires because
the reason why i started making the art
my femdom art is because
there were times when things happened in
a session that were perfect for that
session but i was like oh man what if it
went like this you know and the director
part of my head just started creating
these scenarios and i was like oh what
if i just like made that as a as a
photograph you know come
shoot what i wanted composite it because
i have all those skills to do that and
just that is my art piece and i will
name it and title it appropriately
whatever
well the first one that i ever did in
that nature was called spring nymphs
it's not explicit at all it's actually
just me with the same girl but twice as
twins in like kind of a grecian
new age
portrait of like
spring
you know and that got featured for lgbtq
plus
um uh heritage month
in hollywood
like it got selected and i was so
surprised because i was like wow they
really see value in like what i was
creating um technically it was good
enough to be in a gallery and second you
know they wanted six of them six of my
photos
and so
that kind of really opened the door for
me to keep producing more
and over time i got accepted to downtown
l.a a showing for artists
who created for trauma which was great
because that kind of coincided with what
i was doing
and then i also got accepted to a show
in malmo sweden
and it just worked out that i was going
to be in europe at the time so i was
able to go there and because of the all
of these little things that happened
my my brain kind of just kept pushing
the boundaries and was saying what else
can i do besides photography so i was
like i love film i worked in film and
entertainment
let's make short films
and so
i had enough money at the time to patron
um you know people that i liked
i was in denver for a show and for
working and i found this photographer
who is stellar and she was friends with
a model that i also wanted to work with
and guess what i made it happen by
showing them like hey this is kind of my
storyboards this is the story that i
want to do are you guys into it and they
were and so that was my first all
women's like cast and crew
short film titled cocoon
and it's about taking away a girl's
entity
and making her something else like a
piece of furniture or a bouquet of
flowers
and um that is one of my most viewed uh
films on youtube to today and not only
that but my films have you know reached
other doms in other countries like in
sweden my
i met uh dom there she showed me her
space and it is amazing what some of
these women are capable of doing like
you think of dungeons and you're just
like oh like a man built that or you
know some guy downtown built that and
it's all these like carpenters and like
all these guys she made everything in
her dungeon she literally like
worked with her
you know sub
to create
these contraptions that i've never seen
before and so i started this playlist on
my own youtube channel titled modern
dungeons because i wanted to pay homage
to like all of these women who were like
making their lives happen in the way
they wanted to and like in such creative
ways because you can be creative like me
where i'm doing artwork and photos and
short films but you can also be building
furniture that's never been done before
to suit specific fetishes
how freaking cool is that
it's awesome
so tell me about how you
get clients you advertise online i
assume so there are some sites that have
survived foster sesta um foster sesta
was a law that was passed a couple years
ago to prevent
big companies to advertise sex workers
on their platform that is how people
used to get their work
and
some people even posted on craigslist in
the personal section and all of that is
gone now um so
it's been really challenging for people
even me who has been doing this for
years five years independently
that law was passed when i was becoming
independent and so for me having trying
to push my website out and having other
people find out who i am
has been you know pretty big of a
struggle
because
not only can i not post on these
websites that used to have rapport um
some of these websites have relocated to
like switzerland or some things to be
able to avoid these laws but it's still
really a shot in the dark kind of thing
and then on those platforms you still
have rules that you have to follow
and so it's it's very hard um social
media has been booming for the last five
to ten years so a lot of people started
trying to put their information on there
but again because it's not even sexual
sometimes but because it's a woman in
power sometimes it's a person of color
and power
and it has to do with you know sex or
taboo
um we are restricted i had my instagram
taken down twice
and that almost broke me because i am
literally the artist behind all of my
images
and
for them to take it down without warning
just like that after two to three years
of posting every single day who's going
to see my work you know unless they go
to my website and they have to find my
website first um
and then i expanded to youtube because i
wanted to do short films and i actually
created that in 2017
to answer questions that i kept on
getting you know a lot of the time and
to save my time and to get other people
to know me better as a person
that's kind of how that started but from
there my youtube has exploded into other
different you know playlists and stuff
like that but even my diys which are
harmless you know it's like how to do
something yourself
those have been restricted having guests
on my channel have been restricted
either because of the
you know
topics and such i don't necessarily
curse and so that's not an issue but
it's just a subject matter that is not
available for monetization
i also ended up being demonetized on my
youtube channel so it's been a really
rough journey for me in the sense where
i've had to constantly try to
work around or work with systems that
are producing these laws and
it's a it's an ongoing fight but i
really give power to those who are like
me and who try
to get our message out there that kink
is not a scary
place it's not neces i don't have to be
in a dungeon to play you know it can be
anywhere it's more about the connection
that you make with people the intimacy
that you give people
the
availability of
you know letting them become whoever
they want to be and not judging them for
it and encouraging it and growing with
them with it
that really
makes me keep going
excellent all right miss mara thank you
so much thank you for having me coming
in and sharing your story thank you
thank you very much
you